next question hey David the Red Sox in
your city of Boston just renamed Yaqui
way to Jersey Street to distance
themselves from Tom Yawkey who is a
noted racist what do you think about
this and other renaming zuv Confederate
leaders and other other things there's
also the Yaqui Boston College building
and the Yaqui Mass AB Hospital in Boston
yeah so Yaqui way very very famous place
outside of Fenway Park which was at one
point not a pedestrian street now it's
basically been turned into like a post
security it's almost like a part of
Fenway Park at this point like you can
only get into certain part of it parts
of it with it well on game day on game
days of course it was renamed because
Tom Yawkey has a long history of racism
and it was decided here in Massachusetts
that it's not good and we got to go we
got to get out of that however a lot of
other stuff still has his name although
from what I've read some of those things
like the Yaqui hospital is named after
his wife you know you make the call I
don't know whether she was also racist
but it's the same name I don't really
know so the question is what do I think
about the renaming I am generally in
favor of doing renaming when we seem to
be glorifying movements or ideas that
are discriminatory in natures right so
when you have a school named after
someone fighting against the north
during the Civil War to preserve slavery
that's not where kids should be educated
right so I that that one is very very
clearly on one side of the line AB a
football team being called the
Washington Redskins I think it's out of
touch with modern society I think it
should be changed at this point Yaqui
way guy was a racist I'm fine with it
being changed he was certainly a less
notable racist than some of these others
although within Boston he was more well
known I'm ok with it but I don't know
that I'm out there picketing for that
yeah I mean I don't know I'm a die-hard
Red Sox fan I didn't even know about all
this stuff until about a year ago yeah
apparently the Red Sox were the last
team to racially integrate and they
would you know try black baseball
players out at Fenway and apparently Tom
Yawkey yelled a racial
slur at some of them sure including
Jackie Robinson so I think you have to
reach I think you have to change the
name right so I think now let's talk
specifically about Boston and Yaqui way
Boston as a so-called very liberal North
East City has a big history of racism a
big history of segregation the city is
still significantly segregated by income
and in many cases as well by race there
are long there there's an incredible
amount of documentation of when the
Celtics who had a number of black
players pretty early on the basketball
team the Boston Celtics horrible racism
being hurled at them at the former
Boston Garden so I think that in Boston
we have an extra responsibility to go
out of our way to make sure that we are
not in any way leaving these relics of a
retrograde past in Boston in place so
I'm a gay I'm a for the renaming of
Yaqui way specifically but I do think
that there is a line at which we have to
say wait a second hold on are we going
too far right so something named after
someone who never did anything racist
but it was known that in private he
called the bunch of P a bunch of
Hispanic people something horrible right
like where do we draw the line we got to
be reasonable people at some point I
don't know where the line is and I think
it's always a gray area there's a tough
slippery slope that you could go down
because say Thomas Jefferson U is
against slavery and principle but Owen
slaves should there do anything named
after him right yeah because he's known
for so many other things and George
Washington he famously freed his slaves
after he died which I guess he's revered
for but I always thought of that as well
he freed the slaves once you'd no longer
had a use for them yeah so should we
take out all relics and all mementos of
George Washington I would argue no but
coming up the principle for that I think
is really tough and that this is why the
people who are all about principles and
say once you have the principles you
figured life out I just disagree right
like unless your principle is we don't
ever rename anything and then we could
have things named after you know adolf
hitler or whatever and it would be
absolutely horrifying and i either I
just I don't know the answer but I know
that I'm in favor of institutions that
have the opportunity to do renaming
to really examine it and consider what
is is the goal and what are the merits
and to make the decision that's best for
them